outside right yeah so why you need to
walk around with a sign you're selling
are you doing
um
I'm actually a question I'm actually a
question in it yeah and I said you do
put outside if you want if you want to
attract ants you put you put sugars down
right someone else is going to come
along right no but women don't wear
clothes
come on shut up like stop it so it's
just it's disingenuous if a girl has her
tits out if her girls has her tits out
in a mini skirt you how could you say
you don't want attention because if I go
out in sweats I know nobody's looking if
I go out in a mini skirt with my boobs
out and it's so it's it's like okay if a
guy if a guy walked out in a clown
outfit and then was confused and people
said look that's a clown if you walk out
looking like a hoe and everyone thinks
you're a hoe and now they think his
wife's a hoe listening
looking righteous is all looking good
I've gone to a game club like that where
it's just pure lesbians
no I haven't got a man that's right
with sexy Minds no one is woman walking
out with all her titties out the door no
I've been gay clubs and even if it was a
gay club I still won't go break up with
all my titties hanging out because some
lesbian's gonna go for me because my
titties look good so I want to have them
out on show and when you said the one
thing I don't like about women is that
when when a woman's saying about her man
takes respect and how she is they turn
around and say the man's insecure my man
ain't insecure my man just respects me
and wants me to respect myself and to
respect my body and to respect him so
because my man is telling me Oh he don't
like that when I'm going out with my
dress all up my ass it doesn't make him
insecure right because you don't forget
a man and he'll be an alpha man and he's
on all these Alpha men and they win the
man put stomach in place you saying that
you're insecure and that's why the women
out there single because you don't want
no one to tell you nothing you don't
want to go out with your titties hanging
titties swinging ass hanging and
swinging and you don't think you know
what we're all independent we can do
what we like and no man can tell us
anything because we're easy plus it's
all about having self-respect for you
your man your body and society that
you're in but I do respond
there for two kind of people you're
meant to someone and your babies the
titties are not there for everybody
to eat your food you don't go in the
street in the club and say I'm gonna eat
my food in front of everyone
and he'll be out there sharing to
everybody and here's the other thing
it's like men just want a girl that's
easy to get along with and so if you're
arguing and he can't tell me what to do
it's controlling like like stop and it's
a headache to men it's a headache go
ahead I got one question for you and be
honest you don't blood clot lie to me
you know
are you gonna get upset no because I
know I look good I'm saying your man is
looking at the girl with her titty out
and a bum out your money staring at you
like that
right you guys
what because why is he doing
why you got your teeth right then why
can you look you got your thing up for
others to look at what is the point
you're missing the points
no but what what you're saying here is
right for you you're correct for you
what he's giving you is the man's
perspective this is what you're not
understanding so what else you're within
your rack you're single you're within
your rights to have your titties out
have your back whatever you're within
your rights you get me you look good go
on with your thing but hey what now
there's a consequence yeah but for every
action there's a reaction so when you
look good you're gonna and it's out side
you're gonna attract more you see what
I'm trying to say so what he's saying is
like he's putting the perspective of it
from a man if a man if a man sees that
you're gonna look he's gonna look it you
see what I'm trying to say so obviously
what you're saying about you don't want
attention but the consequence for you
the the reaction for you acting like
that you will get attention but I feel
like that's anything because he said
he's done it for so long I feel like in
today's day and age year women need to
take responsibility for their own
actions you know what I mean like if you
want to go out what's addressing how you
want to dress fine you can do whatever
you want you know I mean but
if you get unwanted attention if you get
guys grabbing you on the street you're
walking trying to walk to a cab and
you've got guys running after you doing
this that any other you can't be shot
yeah because you're putting everything
out on show and you're advertising a
certain way and and you're trying you're
attracting a certain type of man you're
like if you're dressed a certain way
like everyone knows it after the club
yeah all of the wolves are out they're
all looking they're looking to take
something home yeah if you're if you're
standing on the street waiting for a cab
and you've got your teaser and your
asset the wolves are coming
because because they're looking at you
like yes easy you know what I mean but a
lot of a lot of women will be like why
are you coming to me you can't be doing
this you can't be doing that but you got
to take responsibility so I mean like if
if I if I if I went to if I went to the
worst estate in London wearing jewels
watch this that and the other like I I
can I can do what I want I can wear what
I want but there's consequences you know
I'm mean so I feel like women these days
need to actually understand the
consequences to their actions like we
don't live in an Ideal World you know I
mean like like we live in reality we
live in a real world I have a question
do you dress different when you're
single and when you're in a relationship
no I don't and I never have that's why
you're single do you know what you know
what like so I'm single because I wear
what I want no I'm saying like why would
you advertise to to me like like why do
you need that attack if you know you
look good right and so you want a dress
to look good and you want to dress
reveal and dress revealing right to me
that's an advertisement that's saying to
men look at me because men always look
unless you're in like a plastic bag
right always what I'm saying when I'm in
my gym stuff I'm wearing a big baggie no
face okay I'm with you I agree but I'm
saying you're gonna attract would you
say you attract more attention when
you're dressed up super nice boobs out
ass out oh yeah 100 so when you have a
man why would you want to attract
unwanted attention but it's not a thing
like that like my thought process when I
can only speak for myself obviously but
when I'm dressed in how I want it's not
a thought process where I'm thinking oh
I'm dressing revealing because I want to
get attention but I'm saying like men
want a girl that's considerate and
that's being considerate it's thinking
oh you know what he might not like that
I'm getting all this attention
everywhere and you know because I have a
man I'm going to be considerate but it's
like if it could be flipped on the same
side with a woman
I notice it's one thing whenever I make
a point about woman we always have to
flip it on the men this is just a point
about women because I'm sorry men and
women it's not the same no no guys no
girls looking at men the same way that
men look at women we're Beauty right and
it's you know it's not the same so I
think we're constantly coming from why
do we never hold it but we always hold
on it's not a man walking about looking
sexy with his balls hanging out I mean
guys
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible